i think this country should be proud uh
continue to be very proud that the
oxford astrazeneca vaccine remains the
workhorse of global immunization
and we will keep
further measures
in reserve
plan b
we do not see the need now to proceed
for instance with mandatory
certification
but we'll continue
to work with the many businesses that
are getting ready uh such a scheme in in
indeed over 200 events have already used
uh covid certification voluntarily
and it's it's just not sensible to rule
out completely this kind of option now
when we must face the fact that it might
still make the difference between
keeping businesses open at full capacity
or not we will also keep open the option
of mandating
face coverings as they as they have
elsewhere or advising people again to
work from home reflecting the fact that
when you've got a large proportion of
the country as we have now with immunity
then smaller changes can make a bigger
difference and give us the confidence
that we don't need to go back to the
lockdowns of the past and of course
we'll continue to update
our advice to you based on the latest
data
but in the meantime
we are confident in the vaccines that
have made such a difference
to our lives
and we're now intensifying that effort
offering jobs to 12 to 15 year olds on
the advice of the chief medical officers
who've given that advice
based
on the health
wellbeing
and educational prospects
of the children themselves
and
for
over 50s and the
under 50s who are at risk or more at
risk we're now motoring ahead with the
booster program a third dose six months
after your second dose so that's going
to mean we're going to be building even
higher walls of immunization of vaccine
protection in this country
and the uk government has procured at
scale
jabs for every part of the uk and
we'll be sending doses to the devolved
administrations in scotland wales
and northern ireland
kovid is still out there the disease
sadly still remains a risk but i'm
confident that we can keep going with
our plan to turn jabs jab jabs into jobs
jobs jobs and protect the gains that
we've made
together